l'entente de principe venait à peine
d'être confirmé que stephen harper se
précipitaient au micro lui qui
attendaient impatiemment ce moment
depuis le début de la campagne
aujourd'hui est un jour historique il
aura fallu cinq ans de négociations des
semaines de pourparlers intenses et la
crainte que tu n'as choc à la dernière
minute pour finalement arriver au
résultat du pacifique formeront la plus
grande zone de libre échange avec 40% de
l'économie mondiale un marché de plus de
800 millions de consommateurs l'accord
permettra de réduire ou d'éliminer les
tarifs douaniers sur une multitude de
produits canadiens exporté dans les pays
partenaires
le canada se targue d'avoir défendu tous
les intérêts à la table de négociations
les secteurs des métaux de la machinerie
de la production agricole comme le boeuf
le porc et le canola pour honnêtement et
trouver leur compte dans des pays comme
le japon ou les tarifs sont très élevés
mais voilà en contrepartie l'accord
procurera aux onze autres pays un accès
au marché canadien
c'est un accord tout à fait unique c'est
une décision tout à fait unique aux en
fait partie vous n'en fait pas partie
parmi ceux qui avaient exprimé des
craintes
les producteurs laitiers qui voit une
plus grande brèche s'ouvrir seulement
très mauvaise partie de nantes marché a
été ouvert
les pays signataires auront droit à
trois et 1/4 % de ce marché
un compromis qui vient avec une
compensation financière de plus de 4
milliards sur 15 ans pour les
producteurs mais qui inclut les
dédommagements remis dans le cadre de
l'accord de libre échange avec l'ue rang
avec les mesures de compensation nous à
ce rang à la stabilité et le futur de
notre système de gestion de l'offre pour
les générations à venir
mais s'il veut réussir at il à calmer
les craintes du secteur de l'automobile
maintenant que le partenariat
transpacifique
6 litre a considérablement l'entrée au
canada de pièces fabriquées en asie
il n'y a pas de possibilité réaliste
d'être hors de cet accord pour la secte
d'autres modèles cet essentiel pour leur
survie
c'est tentant de principe devra être
entérinée par le prochain parlement
à deux semaines du scrutin s'ils veulent
rappeler lui combien s'en servir pour
convaincre les canadiens de lui accorder
un quatrième mandat
ici mark debout radio canada ottawa